hi guys I'm Greg Alba now I'm John
Humphrey do you like our new set do you
like our new set and now there's a
reason why we're super late to this just
simply we have to be out of this
apartment in less than 24 hours we got a
lot more packing to do including this
camera and all the film equipment and
computers and stuff right now so why
don't even heads up to all of our
subscribers that if anything big drops
between Wednesday through probably we
will probably not be able to cover it on
YouTube you know and it's not something
big drops like this people we won't be
able to I appreciate that love and
support but you know we got personal
life stuff to attend to at the moment
but we do have some videos that have not
been uploaded for April so we're just
gonna upload those you know once a day
for the next few days algorithm film all
right guys they're still gonna be a
plenty of people in the comments being
like skip to 1:30 for the reaction hey
I'm trying to give an important
explanation why if we can't cover
something big this week if something big
comes out and we happen to upload
something that is not big there's a
reason why
[Music]
ah
do spy sagen
people dead there is
when bra mommy charge well be clarified
in a swatch leibrandt hierarchy based on
level of critical importance the
disparity between this is too fast to
modify agent stuff mistakes your basic
[Music]
it's really not that fast
[Music]
[Music]
Oh interesting
yeah oh gosh I thought I thought hit
with the hair was it the costumes like
every go they're keeping him like a very
grounded human for a lot of this the day
James Marcin has a line in a trailer
that is completely funnier than anything
Jim Carrey was funny
well detective Pikachu this is not and
honestly I don't know if detective feet
she's gonna be a good movie for all I
know this movie as it stands what I like
I like that one joke it's you know parts
okay I don't have Sonic nostalgia like
at all
you played the games growing up since
the games I've seen some of the cartoons
right right I've never seen the cartoon
I have only played the games when I'm at
a friend's place and they own a video
game of Sonic so I I didn't have Sega
growing up so I like to me there's no
nostalgia lore here that's being
tampered with so I can't I can't comment
on that at all but I can comment on is
just what this trailer is showing me for
2 minutes and 45 seconds okay I thought
that was a really bad trailer I was and
it's a long trailer too and they have
moments in here that are really playing
out like that whole thing with Jim
Carrey and that guy who should be more
famous Oh
[Music]
nice and I think in the Street Fighter
that Chumlee won this looks like it
would be an annoying movie to sit there
and look it doesn't look like so bad it
would be funny it doesn't look like it
knows what it wants to be this feels to
me as if they didn't know what to do
with it and so they did the formula the
most cliche kind of formula you do with
an adaptation like this in order to try
to make it work you know you make up
that I don't imagine this James Marrs
small town cop and he meets sonic and
sonic has to help with this government
ply the sonic being seen through the
eyes of Jim Larson I got I don't feel
like Sonic even though I just said I
don't know Sonic the backs or anything I
from what I do know about him and how is
this like a charming leading character
already he's got personality does he
need that human sidekick guy you know
like I don't feel like he needs it yeah
the only thing I can really give this
serves like the sonic ability is I think
that there are the moments that look
really cool visually when he like starts
running and he does the ball thing and
yeah her flips over that was one of the
few moments in the trailer was like but
I could be pretty cool there moments
that like you like the action looks cool
like with Marissa like the flash of
Quicksilver because it's songs you know
abilities and also with the ring stuff
like right out of Doctor Strange here I
remember when the design first came out
fans were not happy about it
even fur like decidedly fur oh is that
what they were I thought did we didn't
know about that something about his legs
or so I forgot it was something about
his size the way he was shaped by
probably that too yeah but I know there
was an issue about people kind of being
if he is furry
it feels like a weird attempt to make
him feel more real yeah or more
endearing or something I don't know like
I haven't seen one rendered where he's
just smooth and as I recall him from the
games I mean it was Sonic I mean he is
Hedgehog yeah it would make sense for
deaf fur it's just in all the games you
see in one particular way it just isn't
Illustrated to evoke the look of fur
well actually know what there's a point
or I was about to say you know like I
get past it but at the same time I'm
like Sonic's a pretty iconic yeah for
like 30 years man if you're gonna make
your big-screen adaptation you should
probably stay as faithful as possible
when you can since the character is
animated even in the live-action version
yeah yeah and I'm conflicted I mean I
like of all the choices that they've
made with this I'm like hey maybe the
furqan work over the course of a whole
movie but I know that's the wasn't yeah
it's the least the process least of the
problems oh yeah this does not look like
it has anything really special to offer
other than if you were such a hardcore
Sonic fan and you want to see Sonic do
some stuff on the big screen because
right now this this just looks it
doesn't look uniquely Sonic really looks
rather flat yeah it looks like a lot of
other movies you've seen yeah it's funny
he made the detective Pikachu comparison
the top of this because I think Tim
Miller is involved and it's like at
least as of the cartoon so I gotta
remember Sonic ever talking much in the
game in the cartoon you know he's got
that kind of personality wisecracking
and stuff and the later games he there's
like you know yeah when they get like
that and I think Ben Schwartz is a fine
choice you know it's like in another
universe I could totally see Ryan
Reynolds doing this role if he wasn't
already Pikachu it's like I think Jim
Carrey is a great choice to play dr.
Robotnik especially at the end when he's
like the full character design with the
crazy mustache and the goggles and all
that stuff but I wonder how much of this
movie he's gonna spend being sort of
subdued Robotnik being in disguise well
I'm like I almost wonder if this is the
movie that's gonna give you kind of what
you wanted but only at the very end I
guess they're building up for us French
this franchise yeah that's definitely
like a very entails and Michael's in
here too yeah oh we're gonna have them
all show up at the yeah shake it up
Shadow the Hedgehog with no it's gonna
be a post-credits scene yeah it's gonna
be literally hosts credits
when you could have just made a cool
song movie filled the world of the sonic
characters instead of this I don't we're
trying to be more that something the
filmmakers have said needs to be more
grounded I don't know I mean they said
they're aiming for a family audience
which I can kind of see and and in that
sense I can sort of like a sonic show
yeah and then you watch the cartoons I
mean a lot of the cartoons are pitched
at younger children's so light-hearted
video camera around the woods in various
nature places collecting rings and
trying to thwart the doctor from turning
all your friends in a robot and so like
I'm wondering like what's this
government plot why are they hiring dr.
Robotnik to help with it you know like I
don't know yeah I I don't have a lot of
faith in this right now and I did not
love the choice to go with gangster's
paradise whatever made no sense yeah
sometimes you hear the popular song or
you know one of those covers you like
maybe pick up a line or two that makes
you go oh I get why they use this but
this I'm like what this sonica gangsters
that is that what we're supposed to take
away from them it could be all right it
could be but I don't know I hope James
Marsden is good he's always he's always
good at being good and stuff that's
otherwise not thank you this is a
divisive film I imagine comment below
subscribe to the real rejects click the
notification bow I should do